in a previous episode we talked about
how critter junction acquired another
company and had to integrate their vms
with their existing architecture
this had gone well so far but critter
junction had noticed some areas where
things could be improved
using google cloud persistent disks to
save money
and to make the entire application more
scalable
stay tuned to see how
after the big acquisition critter
junction had to maintain
and ideally upgrade another company's
vms
after using the architecture for a few
months one of the first potential areas
of improvement critter junction found
was that there were many of these vm's
discs that were being underutilized
meaning the speed at which the
application was requesting data
was much slower than the speed their
disks could read the data
and they realized that other parts of
the architecture were over utilizing
resources
so critter junction also realized if
their growth projections were accurate
they would need to resize their vm's
disks as they would very quickly outgrow
their current disk
size and on top of all that they wanted
this resizing to happen without any
downtime or costly vm restarts
if possible this seemed like a lot to
ask for but what they didn't know is
that google cloud persistent disks solve
a lot of their problems
let's dig in google cloud persistent
disks are a durable
high performance block storage option
for cloud vms
their main benefit is that they can be
attached to or detached from
vms as needed allowing for long-lived
data to persist
even where those vms are started stopped
or terminated
there are three different types of block
storage
local ssds are high performance scratch
spaces that are best suited for
in-memory databases up to nine terabytes
in size
then there's standard persistent disks
these are network devices suited for
large data processing workloads that
primarily use sequential ios
there are ssd persistent disks which are
suited for enterprise applications and
high performance database needs
that require lower latency and more iops
than standard persistent disks provide
ssd persistent disks are designed for
single digit millisecond latencies
the observed latency is app specific
and finally there are balance persistent
disks
which as named provide a balance between
pd standard and pd ssds
they are backed by a solid-state drives
that balance performance
and cost now that we reviewed the
different types
let's see how this applied to critter
junction critter junction
mostly uses standard persistent disks
which are good for
using as boot devices persisting data
use as data distribution devices for
static website content
and they can be a useful way to
replicate data across zones
unfortunately the current architecture
didn't take much advantage of these
features because each pd
is attached to a corresponding vm as we
mentioned
this caused the application to under
utilize some pd's while
over utilizing others another concern
critter junction had
is that as their application data and
boot volume grows
they're afraid they'll have to reboot
the vm detach the pd
resize it and reattach it resulting in
scaling limits with downtime
fortunately this isn't the case at all
what critter junction didn't know
is that persistent disks provide
scalability because multiple vm
instances can connect to content at the
same time within the same zone
allowing applications to scale up or
instances down
as needed to serve data to customers and
better yet
attaching a persistent disk to multiple
virtual machines
doesn't affect total performance or cost
either
each machine gets a share of the per
disk performance limit
performance scales automatically with
size so you can resize
existing pd's or add more pd's to an
instance to meet performance and storage
space requirements
each pd can be up to 64 terabytes in
size
so there's no need to manage arrays of
disks to create large logical volumes
critter junction also didn't realize
that persistent disks provide
nearly unlimited flexibility by allowing
you to resize your storage
while it's in use by one or more virtual
machines
with no downtime that means they could
resize their disks
on the fly without interruption
this is all made possible by google
cloud persistent disks being network
attached
since the disks aren't physically
attached to the vms that are using them
you get the benefit of using google's
network fabric which can deliver more
than one petabit per second of total
bisection bandwidth
that's a lot of that with all of this
new information
critter junction went ahead and moved
away from assigning one pd
per vm this allowed them to connect more
vm instances to their underutilized
disks
these instances all read from the same
standard persistent disk
allowing the entire application to serve
more users
and for the disks that were over
utilized critter junction decided to
upgrade them to larger disks
and best of all critter junction took
advantage of google cloud persistent
disks ability to resize a storage
while it's in use by a vm to do all of
this without any downtime
for critter junction google cloud
persistent disks turn out to be a simple
fast and flexible solution for those
needs
so that's a wrap for this episode of
season of scale
stay tuned for more about critter
junction and remember
always be architecting